installation électrique vetus
dégradation charpente qui s'affaisse en
France de plus en plus d'églises se
délabrent faute d'entretien depuis la
loi de séparation de l'État et de
l'église les édifices construits avant
1905 sont en majorité propriété des
communes de ce fait ces dernières sont
en principe tenues de financer la
rénovation et l'entretien des bâtiments
à leur propre frais mais au vu de
l'étendue des dégâts et des coûts de
travaux croissants faudra-t-il se
résoudre à raser des églises
commençons par un état des lieux pour
bien comprendre l'ampleur du chantier la
France compte aujourd'hui environ 42 500
églises l'immense majorité disons 40 000
appartient aux communes les autres
construites après 1905 sont la propriété
de l'Église catholique et donc à la
charge du culte parmi les édifices gérés
par les communes 15000 sont protégés au
titre des monuments historiques dans ces
cas-là l'État doit prendre sa part quant
au 154 cathédrales 87 d'entre elles
appartiennent directement à l'état et la
majorité des 67 autres sont propriétés
des communes le problème de délabrement
se pose principalement pour les édifices
non classés qui sont eux entièrement à
la charge des communes selon
l'Observatoire du patrimoine religieux
5000 édifices pourraient être abandonnés
vendus ou détruit d'ici 2030 certains
sont d'ores et déjà menacées voire fermé
le 5 avril 2021 un incendie se déclare
dans la collégiale Saint-Nicolas à
Avesnes-sur-Helpe dans le nord de la
France
[Musique]
on est en fin de journée je reçois un
coup de fil il y a le feu à la
collégiale vraiment j'ai ressenti un
thème cataclysme dans ma personne pour
l'instant donc il y a pas de travaux
entre prix un premier nettoyage a été
assuré l'architecte du patrimoine
à chiffrer chiffrer une Renault
rénovation globale de la collégiale qui
on a bien besoin
et du fait ça se chiffre d'un montant
très important autour de 6 millions
d'euros
il y a d'un côté les édifices qui ont
subi des dégradations ou des accidents
mais il y a aussi ceux qui tombent en
ruine à cause du manque d'entretien la
question est comment en sommes-nous
arrivés là sur les 42
000 églises il y en a 40 000 qui
appartiennent aux communes et plus ce
chiffre a retenu et que 75% d'entre
elles sont dans des communes de moins de
3000 habitants alors quand on a 3000
habitants on a très peu de ressources
très peu de ressources de fiscales on ne
peut pas tellement lever de l'argent
comme ça on se retrouve avec un bâtiment
religieux qui est de moins en moins
fréquenté parce qu'on sait qu'il y a une
baisse de la pratique religieuse en
France
et il faut l'entretenir et donc on n'a
pas d'argent donc on a cet état des
lieux d'un perpétuel manque de moyens
face à un perpétuel besoin croissants de
travaux et les deux courbes ne se
croisent pas un maire
il a quand même d'autres priorités que
la restauration de ces bâtiments et de
l'école les routes le rond-point ça
c'est la sécurité tout ça ce sont des
questions cruciales tout de même donc
les restaurations de patrimoine et de
bâtiments c'est toujours trop cher face
à ces difficultés les communes n'ont que
peu de solutions pour sauver leurs
églises elles peuvent soit faire des
demandes de subvention soit se tourner
vers des associations alors à la
Fondation du Patrimoine donc on
considère qu'il ne faut pas effacer
notre histoire et abandonner notre
patrimoine religieux
de même que Notre Dame on n'a pas laissé
brûler et on a mobilisé des sommes
durable pour le sauvegarder mais il faut
faire la même chose pour toutes nos
petites Notre Dame ensuite la décision
elle appartient aux propriétaires des
lieux ou aux élus notamment et aux
habitants savoir est-ce qu'ils ont une
affection pour se batiment ou pas et
notamment est-ce qu'on peut lui redonner
un usage lorsque l'église n'est plus
fréquentée ou plus souvent fréquentées
est-ce qu'elle peut servir à d'autres
activités notamment culturelles
depuis les années 2000 au moins une
vingtaine d'églises ont déjà été
détruites d'autres devront-elles subir
le même sort aujourd'hui environ 500
édifices sont fermés
[Musique]